bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui va mettre tout le monde
d'accord ou pas sur les désaccords
commerciaux
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'accord l'accord qui a été
signé entre la chine et les états unis
accord commercial donc un bon jour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches les états unis et la chine sont
ils en train d'enterrer la hache de
guerre dans la guerre commerciale qui
les oppose donald trump at il eu raison
de s'attaquer à la chine depuis 2018 les
deux pays se sont attaqués mutuellement
à coups de droits de douane punitifs sur
des centaines de milliards de dollars de
marchandises
le 15 janvier dernier les deux parties
ont signé la première phase d'un accord
commercial
une étape historique pour reprendre les
mots de donald trump
on écoute le président américain s'était
juste après la signature aujourd'hui
nous franchissons une étape importante
qui n'a jamais été franchie auparavant
avec la chine vers un avenir de commerce
équitable est réciproque
alors que nous signons la première phase
de l'accord commercial historique entre
les etats-unis et la chine ensemble nous
redressons l'étang du passé et nous
offrant un avenir de justice économique
et de sécurité aux travailleurs aux
agriculteurs et aux familles américaines
olivier avec cet accord la guerre
commerciale entre la chine et les états
unis et est derrière nous non bien sûr
que non
elle est devant elle n'a jamais été
autant devant que maintenant cet accord
c'est un accord politique pour des
raisons internes de politique intérieure
que ce soit d'ailleurs pour les en ce
qui concerne les chinois qu'en ce qui
concerne les américains je vous rappelle
que monsieur trump
étant en phase pré électorale et donc il
a besoin d'avoir un accord pour
vis-à-vis de la population intérieur qui
va bientôt voter donc c'est pas le début
d'un accord en quoi que ce soit d'abord
parce que cette guerre elle est beaucoup
plus profonde que juste une guerre
commerciale sur des sur des niveaux de
de taxation ou autre c'est aujourd'hui
la chine qui remet en cause l'hégémonie
américaine donc je pense qu'on en ré
entendra parler après les élections et
que là aujourd'hui c'est une toute
petite bataille qui a été ou est on a
enterré la hache de guerre pendant
quelques mois il y en a tout de même à
s'intéresser au contenu de cet accord
que contient exactement ce texte on voit
cela avec le tiroir qu'acheter antoine
maes
il fallait bien un accord pour régler
ces chamailleries commerciales entre la
chine et les usa
depuis des mois elle avait des
répercussions sur toute l'économie
mondiale
alors qu'une posture dans cet accord
déjà la chine s'est engagée à apporter
plus de produits américains sûrs deux
ans 200 milliards de dollars de plus par
rapport à 2010 est en échange trump lui
s'engage à ne pas mettre en place de
nouvelles taxes douanières
ton maintenant c'est qu'ils sont déjà en
place du moins jusqu'à la phase 2 de
l'accord vous n'avez pas dit cette
première signature n'était que la phase
la phase 2 elle promet d'être compliqué
les etats unis sont en ligne de mire des
subventions massives de l'état chinois à
ses industries sidérant cela comme de la
concurrence déloyale au niveau
international preuve également ce qu'il
considère comme le vol par la chine de
la propriété intellectuelle des
entreprises américaines et demande que
des dispositions juridiques
contraignantes sur mise en classe pour y
mettre fin
avec genre des grosses amendes bien
dissuasive
bref c'est pas encore gagné un premier
pas a été fait enfin reste à savoir si
la chine dont l'économie subit un gros
ralentissement jouera bien jeu et si
elle signera aussi et la phase 2 de
l'accord
olivier daunais trump a jugé à cet
accord je suis bien meilleur qu'il ne le
prévoyait vous quel est votre avis sur
le contenu
le contenu de cet accord des mots vous
avez une chine qui est en ralentissement
donc ça m'étonnerait déjà qu'ils
importent de 100 milliards de plus ils
en seraient bien incapables et donc vous
signez quelque chose qui sera pas
réalisée mais à la limite je pense que
trump l'a déjà là déjà pris en compte
c'est à dire que je vous dis tout ce qui
l'intéresse c'est cesser sa réélection
et le reste passe après donc c'est un
espèce de jeu de rôle si vous voulez et
je pense que les chinois sont aussi dans
une dans une optique de ralentissement
qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir ces ses
déclarations d'intention parce que ça ne
sont que des déclarations d'intention
donc le il le vrai la vraie phase 2
c'est à dire je dirais la plus
contraignante
je suis pas certain qu'elle sera signée
et qu'elle sera signé en temps et en
heure donc voilà je vous ai dit
aujourd'hui je pense que ça va bien au
delà d'une simple guerre commerciale et
et que on a un pays qui est la chine qui
est qui est aujourd'hui presque aussi
puissante que les états unis et la
remise en cause de l'hégémonie
américaine ne plaît pas aux américains
bon ça on pouvait s'en douter merci
olivier allez on va ouvrir la deuxième
partie de cette émission et pour cela
nous recevons cette semaine est sylvie
matelly économistes et directrice
adjointe de l'iris l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques
bonjour sylvie matelly jeu merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation bienvenue dans ces caches
alors on l'a évoqué en première partie à
la chine et les usa ont signé un accord
le 15 janvier dernier selon vous la
guerre commerciale est elle terminée
alors la guerre commerciale n'est pas
terminé on est en pause en trêve parce
que les deux parties avaient un
véritable intérêt à ce qu on calme le
jeu quelques temps donald trump a
beaucoup été dit pas ce qu'il entre en
campagne et qu'il avait besoin pas temps
de calmer le jeu mais plus d'accumuler
des succès et c'est un succès c'est un
succès pour lui et il a bien présenté
comme tel
et puis les chinois parce qu'il se
retrouve quand même confronté un certain
nombre de difficultés alors c'était le
ralentissement économique depuis
plusieurs années ça a été les événements
à hong kong également et puis plus
récemment la crise sanitaire qu'il
traverse
donc il n'avait pas besoin en plus d'une
guerre commerciale qui s'amplifie il
était bien content que les choses se
calment et sur l'accord même donald rome
l'a qualifiée d' historique pour les
vielles c'est plutôt un accord politique
donc vous qu'est-ce que vous quel est
votre avis là-dessus
oui c'est un accord historique si on
considère que c'est le premier vrai
accord suivies de faits delà de cette
guerre commerciale
ça reste malgré tout un élément assez
assez logique dans cette guerre
commerciale et dans la relation etats
unis chine je suis pas sûr que ça marque
un changement profond et structurel des
relations établies par le président
trompé l'administration américaine entre
la chine et les états unis
ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
effectivement quelque chose de très
politique c'est que les sujets qui sont
listées
on n'en sait pas grand chose à part les
200 milliards de
d'importation que compromis la chine
d'importation américaine compromis la
chine
par contre le nom les sujets évoqués il
y en a sept on n'a pas tous les citer
mais parmi les sujets évoqués il ya la
plupart des dossiers qui fâchent la
question du taux de change
la question du respect de la propriété
intellectuelle la question des
subventions aux entreprises de la part
des autorités chinoises et c'est donc on
a fait une liste un peu à la prévert des
sujets qui gênait les américains et
c'est vrai que de ce point de vue tout
outil y est quasiment olivier une
réaction alors c'est assez drôle
d'entendre injustement parler du taux de
change parce que le dollar n'est jamais
manipulé en rien bien sûr donc non c'est
l'hôpital qui se fout de la charité là
dessus mais dans tout ça tous ces points
font partie de la phase 2 1 pas du pas
de la première signature
la première signature c'est la promesse
des chinois les promesses n'engagent que
ceux qui les croient et donc la promesse
des chinois de daim portée de 100
milliards de plus vu pour l'instant
l'état de ralentissement de la chine
moi les 200 milliards je veux les voir
je suis pas sûr qu'on les verra alors on
écoutait à donald trump en première
partie d'émission on va à présent
écouter le vice premier ministre chinois
négociateur en chef de pékin sur le
commerce
le souci est un accord lie l'ue
tuellement bénéfique et gagnant gagnant
il va stabiliser le développement
économique mondiale promouvoir la paix
la prospérité et il est dans l'intérêt
des producteurs les consommateurs et des
investisseurs dans le pays
en même temps cet accord n'est pas
dirigée contre et n'aura pas d'incidence
sur les droits et intérêts légitimes de
tous pays tiers il est conforme aux
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
un accord un accord gagnant gagnant ça
dépend de quel point de vue on se place
serait que les chinois ont cédé sur
beaucoup de points je pense qu'ils
jouent la montre aussi ils savent très
bien que ils ont jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour se mettre en accord avec
cet accord pour acheter 200 milliards de
produits américains
croiser les doigts pour que les
élections américaines ne soient pas
favorables au président train pour
l'imaginent parce que là la guerre
commerciale reprendrait de plus belle
du côté américain on n'a pas beaucoup
d'informations sur ce qui a été cédée à
part le la non-imposition de nouveaux
droits pendant un certain nombre de mois
c'est quand même très faible par rapport
à ce qui a été concédée par la chine
par contre il est clair que la chine et
on l'a vu depuis le début de cette
guerre commerciale avec un beaucoup plus
à perdre que les états unis dans cette
guerre commerciale faut rappeler que la
chine le premier marché chinois c'est
des états unis alors qu'on inverse pour
les etats-unis le marché chinois n'est
que le troisième marché derrière le
canada et le mexique
donc on est sur des enjeux qui sont très
différents et finalement les états unis
avait plus à gagner qu'à perdre est la
chine beaucoup plus à perdre que les
états unis donc bien évidemment il était
logique dans ce rapport de force que les
chinois sont prêts à céder plus alors
les états unis vont tout de même
maintenir des droits de douane sur plus
de 370 milliards de dollars de produits
chinois tant que la deuxième phase de
l'accord ne serait pas signé
comment expliquer finalement que la
chine aussi que la chine est clairement
perd un peu de terrain
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
a beaucoup en tout cas l'administration
américaine a beaucoup insisté sur le
fait qu'elle n'imposerait pas de
nouveaux droits de douane mais faut bien
entendre de nouveau c'est à dire les
anciens restent et rien ne change de ce
côté là et en fait encore une fois on
est dans une situation le rapport de
forces n'était pas favorable à la chine
qui outre la relation commerciale
qu'elle a et qui est beaucoup plus
importante pour elle avec les états unis
que l' inverse
il est clair que il ya aussi toutes les
difficultés que rencontrent aujourd'hui
la chine difficultés économiques
difficulté pour les difficultés sociales
qui font que se ralentir au réduire la
pression de ce côté là était était
urgent pour ce pays voyez vous avez
depuis la déclenchement de cette guerre
commerciale le déficit vis-à-vis de la
chine le déficit commercial américain
vis-à-vis de la chine même plutôt évolué
en hausse donc ne s'est pas réduit du
tout donc très peu et donc ce qui prouve
bien que pour l'instant en tout cas les
droits de douanes n'ont pas eu un effet
extraordinaire sur leur sur leurs
importations que je suis pas convaincu
tout de même une que le jeu ne soit pas
plus équilibré qu'il n'y paraît c'est à
dire que je je je suis d'accord sur le
fait que la chine a beaucoup à perdre
puisqu'elle exporte beaucoup aux états
unis mais enfin il ya quand même aussi
énormément d'entreprises américaines qui
sont implantées en chine dont apple dont
les fleurons de de l'industrie
américaine et puis et puis il ya une
deuxième chose il ya aussi ces histoires
de terres rares dont pied dont les
américains ont besoin et je rappelle que
c'est la chine qui en a le
quasi-monopole même le monopole
d'ailleurs du traitement puisqu'ils ont
racheté le seul le seul endroit où on
produisait du dp rare aux états unis
donc à ils sont propriétaires de ça
aussi
donc on a on a quelque chose qui à mon
avis est plus acquis libre est qu'il n'y
paraît bien que y ait beaucoup de
produits chinois et surtout des produits
chinois de bas de gamme qui soit
exportée aux états unis alors on va
marquer une courte pause et on revient
dans un instant bienvenue dans ces
caches si vous nous rejoignez on parle
de l'accord signé entre la chine et les
états unis avec sylvie matelly
économistes et directrice adjointe de
leiris l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques
alors on l'a vu en sept ans d'accord qui
en deux phases pourquoi deux faces
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi ne
pas avoir tout signé d'un coup il
fallait un accord il fallait signer
quelque chose et que c'est très facile
de s'engager
c'est beaucoup plus difficile ensuite
vous l'avez dit une reddition d'aller
dans le coeur du sujet et de régler
vraiment les les tous les dossiers je
pense que l'ambition affichée pour la
phase 2 est énorme ici mais que c'est
plus de l'affichage pour donald trump en
particulier de dire regardez tout est
sur la table et on négocie tout à fait
c'est un gros gros coup de com
par contre là où il a quand même été
très fort et on peut dire qu'il a en
partie réussi c'est que globalement les
exportations de la chine vers les etats
unis se sont fortement réduits en 2018
et en 2019 alors que les importations
américaines était stable voire augmente
et un tout petit peu donc on a quand
même eu une réduction du déficit
commercial sa c c'était assez inattendu
au départ par contre ce qui est certain
et l'aca handicapés c'est un vrai sujet
pour le président trump et ça
rééquilibre effectivement la relation
c'est qu'il ya des secteurs qui sont
particulièrement touchés faut savoir
qu'il ya trois grands secteurs qui est
excédentaire trois grands secteurs
d'activité américain qui est
excédentaire dans l'eure dans leur
commerce avec la chine c'était le
secteur de l'agriculture le secteur de
l'électronique et le secteur des
transports
boeing par exemple le premier marché de
boeing aujourd'hui c'est la chine on
voit les difficultés que rencontrent
boeing qui sont pas liés
et à la guerre commerciale mais ça
n'arrange pas les affaires de bruyne
donc vous avez un certain nombre de
secteurs d'activité aux états unis qui
ont été lourdement impactés et pas de
bol pour le président entre il se trouve
que c'est en grande partie des gens qui
votent pour lui et qui votent
massivement pour lui donc on a vu aussi
dans la négociation et ça je crois que
c'était important
alors on n'a pas tellement
d'informations sur les 200 milliards que
doivent acheter chinois sur deux ans sur
deux ans tout à fait on a quelques
indications de secteurs d'activité on
voit que transports agriculture et
arrivant électroniques arrivent en tête
il paraît que il ya une partie de
l'accord restée secrète qui listent
produit par produit ce qui doit être
achetée par les chinois d'avoir
effectivement si ça se confirmera dans
les faits donc les chinois vous le
disais se sont engagés sur deux ans et
après c'est ce que je vous disais moi je
pense que le au delà de la guerre
commerciale sur les droits de douane et
et autres autres
plaisanterie je pense que derrière il ya
quand même une volonté des chinois he
depuis d'ailleurs plus de plus de deux
ans qui est de prendre la main de 2 de
ceux des dollarisée de de ne plus
dépendre justement des états unis est
qui et qui est beaucoup plus profond que
la simple guerre commerciale qui est le
légume de la vague quoi et que derrière
il ya cette idée de s'affranchir de
l'hégémonie américaine et est de faire
descendre de son piédestal l'ailé les
états unis qui aujourd'hui est le maître
du monde donc voila et ça si vous voulez
le le fait de reculer d'un pas c'est
probablement pour mieux avancer derrière
donc voilà il ya une phase 1 ont cessé
politique ccc pour que c'est pour calmer
un petit peu le jeu c'est pour pas
soufflé sur les sur les braises
maintenant on prendra les choses
sérieuses et les discussions sérieuses
dans dans un an
et là je pense que ça risque d'être un
petit peu plus compliqué que ce qu'on
nous annonce que nouvellement donne être
attaqué la chine à court terme dans son
intérêt personnel et politique
probablement à moyen ou long terme comme
vous venez de le dire c'est certaines
pas là certainement pas la bonne méthode
parce qu'effectivement les chinois ont
les moyens de se désolidariser de
l'économie américaine beaucoup plus vite
qu'on ne l'imaginent on voit ces jours
ci qu'ils sont en train de construire
des hôpitaux en dix jours mon reste à
savoir ce que ça va donner au bout de
dix jours mais très clairement
on sait que la chine est un pays moteur
est un pays qui avance très vite est un
pays qui peut beaucoup plus rapidement
que n'importe quel autre pays du monde
se passer des etats-unis réduire sa
dépendance aux états unis et entraîné
avec elle en plus un certain nombre
d'autres pays européens clu voilà donc
on a tout intérêt et les chimot le
lorrain outre donald trump le reste du
monde a tout intérêt à ce rééquilibrage
des puissances et il est bien évident on
le voit aujourd'hui avec les européens
et la décision qui a été précieux huawei
on voit bien que les européens ont aussi
intérêt à ce que ce rééquilibrage se
produisent assez rapidement et là du
coup la guerre commerciale n'était pas
du tout dans l'intérêt des états unis à
long terme
alors justement un mot sur le commerce
mondial on l'a écouté tout à l'heure le
vice premier ministre chinois qui a dit
en parlant de l'accord il va stabiliser
le développement économique mondiale
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
déclaration non dans l'absolu parce que
la guerre commerciale n'est pas terminée
comme le disait au tout début
ce qu'on voit bien dans la séquence
d'événements qui se passe en chine
depuis plusieurs mois c'est que les
chinois ont besoin de restaurer la
confiance
ils ont une croissance économique qui
affaiblit une consommation intérieure
qui ne sont qui n'évolue deux camps sans
tâche du pib ça c'est une véritable
faiblesse pour l'économie chinoise dans
sa volonté de devenir plus autonomes par
rapport pas seulement aux états unis
mais par rapport à sa dépendance au
commerce extérieur donc on a des
déclarations aussi du côté chinois qui
vise à rassurer des déclarations des
actions qui visent à rassurer à
restaurer la confiance
on est dans la déclaration est dans la
communication plus que dans une réalité
et laissez votre avis oui puis je crois
que en fait que quand vous disiez est-ce
que trump avait un intérêt à 7 a
déclenché cette guerre comment ça je
crois que c'est surtout en réaction
c'est à dire que ils s'aperçoivent
qu'ils sont en train de perdre la main
s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont en train de
perdre leur statut de superpuissance et
d'unique superpuissance et donc il
fallait réagir et il a réagi parce que
il sait que à terme il va perdre risque
de perdre cette place est donc alors la
réaction a été à la trump c'est à dire
assez brutal mais mais c'est quand même
une espèce de deux comédies c'est bien
joué c'est un pas deux plus que plus
qu'autre chose et donc je pense qu'ils
sont ils sont en réalité
enfin ils font semblant d'être d'être
d'accord sur sur un petit accord qui
finalement ne les engage pas à grand
chose
pour terminer sur la chine et les états
unis est ce que d'une guerre commerciale
on peut on peut passer sur une guerre
numérique avec huawei la 5g on l'a vu au
wake est toujours exclue à des états
unis et ce qu'elle peut se déplacer
cette base on est déjà dans une guerre
technologique et numérique très
clairement avec quand on rapproche
huawei de l'armée chinoise on peut aussi
rapproché des intérêts technologiques
américains des intérêts du pentagone
américain
on est dans quelque chose qui est très
stratégique au fond cette cette question
technologique et la guerre est déjà
engagée entre ces deux superpuissances
très clairement et incontestablement
elle est aussi les métiers vous restez
avec nous on va parler de l'actu de la
semaine l'actualité de la semaine
marquée par le havre excite bien
évidemment ça y est le royaume uni est
officiellement sortie de l'union
européenne
qui change de visage et devient l'europe
des 27
alors olivier d'accord de sortie qui a
été signé garantit une période de
transition période de transition qui
pourrait aller jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020
au plus tôt et au plus tard s'est
terminée en 2022
pour autant est ce que concrètement
sache où est ce qu'il y aura des
changements pendant cette année de
transition
oui il va y avoir une période de
transition maintenant - boris johnson a
déjà annoncé que la fin ça serait de 31
décembre 2020 et que ça serait pas 2022
donc voilà donc là on sait déjà le
calendrier pour l'instant il les tient
ses calendriers donc ici il l'avait il
avait quand même enfin faut quand même
voir que cette affaire dure depuis trois
ans que elle n'avait pas avancé jusque
finalement jusqu'au 12 décembre que la
boris johnson a une majorité et que fait
ce qu'il avait dit c'est à dire il sort
alors je pense que là la situation a
bien été résumé d'ailleurs de cette
histoire par le dernier discours de
nîmes fage où il dit
les anglais aiment le rock mais pas
l'union européenne et je pense que
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de pays qui
sont dans ce cas là aujourd'hui et c'est
ça qui fait peur d'ailleurs à à l'europe
à l'union européenne et on a vu
d'ailleurs le comportement à ce
moment-là de la présidente de
l'assemblée qui lui a coupé le micro
donc on voit que c'est toujours une
grande démocratie l'union européenne de
transition n'ira pas au delà du 31
janvier 31 décembre 2020 alors moi je me
rappelle un 31 octobre 2019 ou boris
johnson pendant quatre mois qu'il était
premier ministre expliquait je ne
demanderai pas de report je ne
demanderai pas de report on sortira au
31 octobre puis je crois que c'est à
21h20 quelques heures avant minuit qu'il
a envoyé un email à la commission
européenne en demandant si un report
jusqu'au 31 juillet pour point jusqu'au
31 janvier pouvaient lui être accordé
donc je tout ça pour vous répondre j'en
sais rien
effectivement il est assez déterminé
quand il veut quelque chose puisque au
final au 31 janvier le royaume uni est
sorti de l'union européenne
qu'est ce que ce sera avec ou sans
report ça c'est ça c'est la question
sachant que jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020
rien ne change
l'union le royaume uni reste est sortie
de l'union européenne mais reste
respecte toutes les règles de cette
union respecte et bénéficient de tous
les accords sans pour autant avoir voix
au chapitre et participe d'ailleurs au
budget de l'union européenne donc pas
d'impact pour les sétois les citoyens
des deux parties à court terme jusqu'au
31 décembre n'ont pas du tout qu'un
impact merci beaucoup
sylvie matelly d'avoir été parmi nous je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste est
directrice ajointe de l'iris l'institut
de relations internationales et
stratégiques
le débrief à des commentaires olivier
notre précédente émission était
consacrée à la grèce voici à les
commentaires sélectionnés celui de
cagnes 31
les grecs ont fait n'importe quoi
l'europe a accordé un crédit revolving
un surendettés ce que sous curatelle il
donc l'europe n'a pas fait n'importe
quoi en lui accordant ce crédit cds
grecs c'est les grecs les responsables
c'est pas celui qui donne le crédit qui
est responsable
alors qu'il le donne en sachant
parfaitement toute façon il y avait
absolument aucune chance que les grecs
le rembourse enfin je veux dire je vois
pas bien donc en fait la personne qui
est surendetté c'est le responsable et
c'est pas la banque qui lui prêtent
l'argent qui est responsable alors
qu'elle sait pertinemment dès le départ
que ça ne peut pas le faire allez on
passe aux commentaires un dozo m'atteler
on ferait là que pour prêter un pays qui
ne rembourse pas ses dettes
comment olivier delamarche peux
t'affirmer ça mais ben je la firme parce
que d'abord c'est arrivé avec
l'argentine
quand en 2002 l'argentine a fait défaut
ils ce sont la plupart des banquiers se
sont précipités pour lui reprêter de
l'argent pourquoi c'est tout simple
parce que ça devient le seul pays qui
n'a plus de dettes
donc vous avez qu'elle vous avez un pays
qui n'a plus de dettes du tout puisqu'il
a fait défaut et bien donc vous venez
lui re prêter de l'argent
si vous avez quelqu'un vous avez le
choix entre quelqu'un qui est surendetté
à 200% et quelqu'un qui à 0% dette vous
prêtez à qui vous prêtez à celui qui n'a
pas de dette c'est plus intelligent vous
avez plus de chances d'être remboursé un
jour booba est dernier commentaire seul
et de paco saignons sortir de haut et
toujours l'option de faciliter le plus
dur c'est de changer soi même
or c'est la meilleure voie les grecs
doivent devenir des européens de l'ouest
voilà le véritable changement de
paradigme également pour d'autres pays
européens d'ailleurs tels que l'espagne
en choisissant l'option difficile à la
longue on gagne toujours
eh ben vous devriez dire ça
à boris johnson comme quoi sortir de
l'union européenne il est même pas
sortie de l'euro sortir de l'union
européenne c'est quelque chose de facile
et que changer soi même c'est quelque
chose de difficile
non franchement vous ne ferez jamais
vous n'appliquerait jamais les mêmes
règles un pays comme l'allemagne et à un
pays comme le portugal la grèce l'italie
ou l'espagne ça ne marche pas ça ne
fonctionne pas on sait qu appliquer la
même règle donner la même monnaie à des
pays qui sont aussi différents
structurellement ça n'est absolument pas
possible soit le plus rapide est obligé
de se lester est de ralentir soit le
plus faible ne peut pas suivre le rythme
de toute façon quoi qui arrive donc vous
ne faites pas changer un pays comme ça
du jour au lendemain il ya une
population qui a des ressources il ya et
serra et vous ne modifiez pas par un
claquement de doigts en revanche vous
pouvez le faire sortir de l'euro et vous
pouvez à ce moment-là lui redonner des
chances parce qu'il a une autonomie
qu'ils retrouvent et il peut vivre avec
quelque chose qui lui est adaptée
essayez quand vous chaussez du 50 de
marché avec des chaussures qui font
pointures 40
vous allez ment pas vous allez me dire
des nouvelles merci beaucoup olivier
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro en
attendant vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rta cachez vous pouvez aussi
retrouver nos précédentes émissions sur
notre site internet à l'adresse rt
france point tv olivier an dernier mot
accor ou grande comédie plutôt grande
comédie